she and Sean yes along with a creator
that's never got fired
I'm a big fan of Japanese culture
I really am fascinated by Japanese
culture and I've always been that way
but I think it's because I've grown up
really close to a Japanese family
they've known my whole life and every
time I go over to their house all the
food is always amazing every time I go
over there it's like a feast they always
have some thing of Japanese culture
around our who's living something this
family is actually descendants of
samurai and so because of them I
actually got interested in samurai and
just just learning about them I'm just
I'm very intrigued by them this film
takes place in Japan in the 1800s when
samurai weren't really looked towards as
warriors anymore they're just kind of
like a dying Society of people and there
were just a few true noble samurai left
this movie that has just just a villain
of villainous villain Rhee wow this man
is this man's an idiot he was adopted
into a noble life and was thus then
given some sort of position of nobility
he had all these servants he treats them
like dogs he abused his power to every
extent possible and you really start to
loathe this character the samurai code
is that you have to honor those who are
above you in that chain so technically
to follow the samurai code they couldn't
do anything about that however they knew
that not doing anything about it was
also breaking their code of honoring and
protecting the people of Japan so the
samurai hatched a plot to try to
assassinate this leader this film is
entirely spoken in the Japanese language
with English subtitles and that's not
something I'm usually into because I
like to look at a film and appreciate
how it looks not so much the reading
however I barely noticed it in this
movie I was so into the story that it
just didn't bother me after a while from
the title you may assume this is just a
straight action movie but it is not it
is really at its core a drama it's about
these men and the fact that they've all
been raised to believe a certain thing
about honor and respect the code that
they have a samurai and the fact that
they suddenly now have to break this
code because they see this evil person
who is obviously going to bring war upon
Japan it creates a lot of tension in
their hearts and that is really where
the the beauty of this film lies is the
fact that the characters are so well
realized the last 45 minutes of the film
Center on this attempt to assassinate
this man my word
it is choreography at its finest it's
not just like the samurai just come out
and decide to you know get on with their
swords they set traps you know they make
these walls appear to trap these people
in various spots there's no queasy cam3
no stinkin queasy cam thank goodness
this director Takashi Miike I'm sure
I've messed up but he knows how to film
this fan I mean it just looks so
beautiful you film the Japanese
countryside so well there's so many
great scenic shots in this movie I mean
it's almost elegant the way if the
samurai used to be this is just a
fantastic foreign film one of the best
foreign films I've ever seen the last 45
minutes are just the definition of epic
beautifully filmed terrific acting and
now you're gonna ask I have not seen the
Seven Samurai
the Japanese family I am friends with I
told you by the beginning they keep
trying to give me a watch I just haven't
got around to it don't worry it is on my
to-do list I know it's like the samurai
movie one of the better foreign films
I've seen recently sure I know what else
you don't fit